only et reunited the cast of America pot
and can I just say this crew looks
exactly the same if not better yes and
boy do they have some stories to tell
now the movie actually opened 20 years
ago today but to them it still feels
like yesterday what does it feel like to
be back together again
20 years later crazy
pretty great yeah that kind of feels
like yeah honestly whenever I see this
group it just really just takes me back
and it feels like no time has passed and
did you have any idea that you were
making this movie that would still stand
up 20 years later personally I felt like
we were part of something special
and it was really interesting because
this was you know internet was kind of
happening but not obviously in the way
it was today
I was at a function I can the moms and
dads they look at me and they're like oh
you why you got old 20 years ago what
American Pie hit theaters in 1999 not
only was the film an instant phenomenon
but man did it push the envelope sure of
course all these years later they still
get recognized for their wildest lines
20 years later I'd like to hear
everybody's American Pie what they
scream well you can guess what this
alright Oh in this one time at band camp
which was fine before I had children
luckily they don't finish the sentence
but I stand there terrified that they
will do your kids kind of know or do
they have no earthly I and I told your
kids okay good
what does everyone else get they just
call me Stifler's mom they call me
Stifler's mom like I'm confused
mom oh hey Stifler
what do you get um like little girls are
kind of coming up to me and asking my
advice if they should like lose their
virginity I'm like oh my god
I don't know yeah yeah the Saturday
after the movie came out I was walking
and the car came by and the kids in the
car shouted oh my god do the dance do
the dance so of course I did the dance
was on Wilshire Boulevard and I figured
if you did the dance you know but but I
don't get bad as much nowadays I mostly
just get oh it's Adam Sandler talk about
the pot there's pies everywhere that
scene I mean that was a life-changing
scene for you yeah sure was sure it's
not what it looks like it's funny when I
read the script mm-hmm it got to that
scene and I laughed out loud and and
this is before Eugene was even cast so I
didn't really even fully know the the
degree to which it was going to be
hilarious well we'll just tell your
mother that we ate it all and then the
day of filming this scene I had a
complete freak out and I called my
manager in my trailer and I was like am
I really gonna am I really gonna do this
like what if no one sees this
what if absolutely no one sees this and
I just happen and then I'm the iCup I
for no other reason than just I got paid
very little money but then he gave me a
vote of confidence and then I I went in
there and and I and I did it I did it go
urges Lee I did it beautifully and now
we're going to cut to the pie and see
what the pie thing he took my innocence
it's funny you mentioned innocence
because I'm gonna show you oh here we go
what Kara this first time was with my
first serious girlfriend oh I should say
it wasn't all that I had expected it
wasn't all I was hoping for
that's mess
a little bit awkward a little bit weird
but my practice makes perfect
trials and tribulations if they do if
you along the way it's about okay I just
I know for myself I was a walking
hormone during high school well I got a
lot of mosquito bites everywhere it was
awful
when you guys were all set like on set
what was like the camaraderie it's like
this was it that's actually through like
this all the dynamics that are happening
now remember something I was thinking
about Sean I don't know if you want to
get into this but I remember a veiny
phone call that you called me once and
what let's say me phone call can
remember you kind of know where I'm
going day I want to know yeah I got to
say I'm still very flattered by this
phone call Oh Sean do you remember what
happened I mean I'm yeah are we on
covering set secret here huh was there a
little was there a little something
going on say goodbye to tell you know
yeah I'm gonna pass I remember that
listen all I remember is that how sweet
is it that we were young enough that we
were all like really why'd you turn it
down it was like was there anyone who
had a moment together how to hook up or
dated a missed moment this moment yeah
no no I had a crush on Chris a bit of a
crush on Eddie oh no I I actually I had
a crush on Alex the opportunity for me
yeah that was it really
yeah if I could go back I would try to
hook up with Eddie and Sean and I feel
like that's one of my regrets I'm still
caught up the other crush on me anything
you're saying
what do you remember about that premiere
cuz there are a lot of famous oh yeah
sorry that would you know
when it hit night Wow like this is this
big yeah
there were so many people at that
premiere oh my god quite yet famous yet
but they will go be from the birds
Charlize Theron one of the people come
on you will see much more of that
amazing footage from the American Pie
premiere tomorrow plus crazier cast
confessions it was such a blast if you
ever go to band camp Wow
you
[Music]